2 | 0,99999999… = 1 ???
Off 1. Lors d’une course des Jeux Olympiques
de 624 avant Jésus-Christ, Achilles laissa
son adversaire, une tortue, prendre 900 mètres
d’avance. Il paraît évident qu’en courant
10 fois plus vite que la tortue, il finirait
par la dépasser.
Et pourtant, le philosophe grec Zénon semblait
avoir trouvé une preuve qu’Achilles ne
pourrait jamais dépasser la tortue…
Off 2. Pour dépasser la tortue, Achilles
doit revenir à hauteur de la tortue. Mais
pendant ce temps, la tortue aura avancé.
Du coup, maintenant, Achilles doit atteindre
à la nouvelle position de la tortue. Mais
encore une fois, pendant ce temps, la tortue
aura avancé. Et encore, et encore, et encore…
Ce qui conduit à la stupéfiante conclusion
suivante : peu importe le nombre de fois qu’Achilles
atteint une position de la tortue, il ne l’aura
toujours pas dépassée !
Bizarre, hein ? Je vais vous laisser y réfléchir.
Pendant ce temps, je viens réagir au titre
de cette vidéo…
Off 3. Vous avez peut-être déjà vu cette
fameuse preuve. On écrit x = 0.99999… Alors
10x = 9.99999… Mais du coup, quand on calcule
10x-x, les décimales s’annulent toutes.
Et on obtient l’égalité 10x-x = 9. D’où
9x = 9. Et du coup, x = 1 !!!
Autrement dit, on a l’égalité incroyable
0.9999… = 1. Bizarre, hein ? Mais, est-ce
que c’est vraiment vrai ? La preuve qu’on
a donnée est-elle vraiment juste ?
Pour vraiment comprendre cette étrange égalité,
revenons-en à Achilles et la tortue.
Off 4. Quand Achilles atteint la position
initiale de la tortue, il aura parcouru 900
mètres. Comme la tortue va 10 fois moins
vite, elle aura parcouru 90 mètres pendant
ce temps. Pendant qu’Achilles court ces
90 mètres additionnels, la tortue avance
de 9 mètres. Et ainsi de suite. Mettons tout
ça en kilomètres maintenant. Vous me voyez
venir, hein ? La distance qu’Achilles parcourt
se décompose en 0.9 kilomètres + 0.09 +
0.009 + … ce qui semble bien faire 0.9999...
kilomètres.
Et ça, quand on y réfléchit, c’est assez
surprenant. On a une somme infinie de termes
tous strictement positifs. Mais cette somme
infinie est... finie. Et c’est là que réside
la faille du raisonnement de Zénon. Certes,
Achilles sera une infinité de fois derrière
la tortue. Mais ça ne l’empêchera pas
de dépasser la tortue en un temps fini, car
il y a une infinité d’instant dans un intervalle
fini de temps. D’un point de vue mathématique,
tout ce que je suis en train de dire, c’est
qu’un intervalle contient un nombre infini
de points !
En fait, le moment où Achilles dépasse la
tortue est le moment où le raisonnement de
Zénon s’effondre, n’est-ce pas ? Et ça,
c’est particulièrement intéressant. Voilà
pourquoi.
Off 5. On peut calculer la distance qu’Achilles
aura parcouru au moment de dépasser la tortue
d’une toute autre manière. En effet, rappelons
qu’Achilles court ici 10 fois plus vite
que la tortue. Du coup, quand Achilles aura
couru 1000 mètres, la tortue en aura parcouru
100. Mais comme la tortue avait 900 mètres
d’avance, à cet instant, Achilles dépassera
la tortue. Achilles dépasse donc la tortue
au bout d’un kilomètre !
Mais on a dit plus tôt que la distance qu’Achilles
a parcouru se décompose en 0.9 kilomètres
+ 0.09 + 0.009 + … = 0.9999… Et du coup,
doit-on, encore une fois, conclure que 0.9999…
est égal à 1 ?
Pour répondre à cette question, il faut
se demander ce que signifie vraiment une somme
infinie comme 0.9 + 0.09 + 0.009 + … En
fait, on a déjà vu un exemple de somme infinie,
dans le tout premier épisode de Science4All
! Je vous avais dit que 4-4/3+⅘-4/7+...
était égal à π. Mais qu’est-ce que cette
égalité veut dire ? Intuitivement, ça veut
dire que plus je rajoute de termes dans cette
somme, plus je me rapproche de π. Mais du
coup, si la somme infinie 0.9 + 0.09 + 0.009
+ … se rapproche de 1, on devra alors conclure
que 0.9999… = 1.
Off 6. Du coup, il ne nous reste plus qu’à
montrer qu’Achille se rapproche infiniment
près de 1 kilomètre au fur et à mesure
qu’il se rapproche de la tortue. Et bien,
la première fois qu’il atteint une position
de la tortue, Achille se retrouve à 0,1 kilomètres
de 1. La seconde fois, il n’est plus qu’à
0,01 kilomètres. Puis 0,001 kilomètres.
Et ainsi de suite… On voit clairement que
la distance qui sépare Achilles des 1 kilomètres
se réduit à néant au fur et à mesure qu’Achilles
se rapproche de la tortue. Et ça, ça prouve
bien que 0,9 + 0,09 + 0,009 + … est exactement
égal à 1.
En fait, ce que je viens de décrire revient
à faire la soustraction 1 - 0,9999… Posons
l’opération.
Off 7. Pour faire, cette soustraction, remarquons
d’abord que 1 est égal à 1,,0000000…
D’habitude, on apprend à commencer les
soustractions par la droite. Mais on peut
en fait les commencer la gauche aussi.
En fait, comme le faisait remarquer mon prof
de maths préféré, beaucoup de matheux commencent
leurs soustractions à gauche… ce qui est
amusant parce que ça montre qu’ils ne font
pas ce qu’on leur a appris à faire. Bref.
Off 8. Pour faire cette soustraction, il faut
anticiper la retenue qui va venir de la droite.
En effet, à droite, on va devoir faire 0
- 9, du coup, il va y avoir une retenue. Et
l’on doit alors faire 1-1 ce qui fait 0.
Puis, on doit faire 10-9… sauf qu’encore
une fois, il faut anticiper la retenue qui
vient de la droite, si bien qu’il nous faut
en fait faire 10-10, ce qui fait 0. Mais on
tombe à nouveau sur le même problème…
Du coup, on a encore 0 avec une retenue, puis
encore un autre 0… et ainsi de suite. Si
bien que l’on a prouvé que 1-0.99999…
est égal à 0. Autrement dit, 1=0,99999…
Et tout ça m’amène à ce qui est probablement
la question la plus importante de cette vidéo
: pourquoi est-ce que l’égalité 0,9999…
= 1 perturbe ? Pourquoi sommes-nous si mal
à l’aise à écrire cela ?
Et bien, il me semble que ce qui pose problème,
c’est le fait que l’on a deux écritures
différentes, et qu’on a l’habitude de
penser que des choses écrites différemment
représentent des choses différentes. Et
c’est en fait quelque chose d’assez remarquable
que l’on ait découvert une façon d’écrire
les nombres entiers tels que toute combinaison
de chiffre représente un et un seul nombre.
Au zéro à gauche près.
Après tout, il n’y a finalement pas si
longtemps, les “savants” comptaient à
l’aide de X, V et de bâtons, qui permettaient
d’écrire des mêmes nombres de façons
très différentes, comme IIII et IV….
Et bien, ce qui est vrai pour les nombres
sans virgules n’est pas vrai pour les nombres
réels. Certains nombres réels peuvent être
écrits de deux manières différentes. Et
c’est en fait le cas de 1 ! En fait, ceci
est vrai pour tous les nombres rationnels
dont les dénominateurs sont divisibles uniquement
par 2 et 5. Je vous laisse y réfléchir et
vous demander pourquoi…
Ce que j’aimerais retenir de tout ça, c’est
que même dans le monde supposément rigoureux
et bien défini des mathématiques, on peut
découvrir sous un caillou des ambiguités
étranges qui sont simplement dûs à
la manière dont on se représente les vrais
objets mathématiques, qui, dans notre cas,
sont les nombres réels. Même en mathématiques,
les symboles ou les mots peuvent nous induire
en erreur. Vous imaginez bien, j’espère,
que dans le monde réel où les mots ont des
nuances et
des connotations marquées, les ambiguités
sont omniprésentes et la simple utilisation
d’un mot plutôt qu’un autre peut nous
induire en erreur. Or, combien de fois les
gens ont-ils l’impression d’avoir compris
juste parce qu’ils arrivent à mettre un
mot pour décrire le problème ? Combien de
fois
utilisent-ils un mot à
la place d’une explication pour justifier
ceci ou cela ?